un tour de table des associations avec
la nouvelle ministre de la ville nadia
et pour l'un de ses premiers
déplacements dans le cadre de sa mission
de politique de la ville
l'ancien député blinoise n'a pas choisi
mantes-la-ville au hasard la communité
sous la mandature du rassemblement
national jusqu'au 28 juin dernier où le
candidat sans étiquette mais soutenu par
l'union de la droite sami damerdji a été
élu l'enjeu qui va être aujourd'hui pour
la nouvelle équipe municipale c'est
justement de rétablir la cohésion
sociale c'est de ramener la république
parce que quand on décide de retirer des
financements du milieu associatif
c'est quelque part la république qui se
retire la ministre entend réinscrire
mantes-la-ville dans les dispositifs mis
en place à l'échelle gouvernementale
durant six ans les associations 17
sentis abandonnés
elle attend désormais un soutien de la
part de la nouvelle municipalité mais
aussi de l'état on avait besoin vraiment
de cet appui structurelles maintenant
aussi d'un appui logistique c'est à dire
d'une aide d'un accompagnement qui va
permettre à nos à nos associations parce
qu'on est plusieurs associations à
pouvoir mettre en place les projets pour
la commune et pour les habitants de son
côté le maire sami damerdji a souhaité
montrer l'état de l'un des gymnases
qu'il estime délabré car non entretenues
par la municipalité précédente
cette visite était l'occasion de dresser
un bilan pour pouvoir aller de l'avant
et entamer la première étape du
programme pour lequel il a été élu
la cohésion sociale et la réconciliation
des générations et des quartiers
beaucoup d'attentes mais également
beaucoup d'espoir et on a eu une oreille
attentive
la part de l'état donc au travers de
madame la ministre avec laquelle donc on
va pouvoir nouer un dialogue qui n'a
jamais existé pendant six ans en tout
cas montrent la ville est inscrite dans
le dispositif quartiers d'été du
ministère de la cohésion des territoires
pour renforcer les activités dans les
quartiers prioritaires et compte lancer
la mise en place de centres de vie
sociaux dès la rentrée pour une
effectivité en janvier 2021